hälfte kommt zu einer neuen folge ich
fahre leute ich bin heute in düsseldorf
und leute heute gibt es eine absolut
geisteskranke folge jetzt schon im titel
gesehen f8 tribut
[Musik]
120 ps fahren wir heute da drüben ist
mein leben heißt auch sebastian
passenderweise ganz wichtige
informationen für euch leute in dem
moment wo dieses video online gegangen
ist ist auch auf dem kanal von ferrari
düsseldorf mit denen ich
zusammengearbeitet habe hier ein video
online gegangen wo die eine ferrari enzo
getestet haben heute dass er ein auto
was über zwei millionen kostet linkes in
der beschreibung der erste track dass
auf jeden fall ab jetzt kommt mit ihr
weil jetzt ist nicht roma jetzt ist die
fusion geht sowas christian hamann
kleiner fällt meiner seite erst mal das
erstmal ausloten wie soja 488 nachfolger
und der nachfolger und wir nachts ist
sehr gefragt und kleiner telefoniere ich
dachte bis vor kurzem das ist dass der
fc porto hat leider nur zwei tore ja
aber das tribute bedeutet quasi tribut
an die verfolger bzw 118 54 und
natürlich an den legendären v8 motor von
ferrari der auch wieder in diesem
schönen stück hinten verbaut ist absolut
der also wirklich der typische typische
ferrari v8 mittelmotor heck 720 ps
geiles geiles geiles ding läuft ich weiß
nicht genau wann ich das hier sehe aber
für mich heute ist heute drehtag weil
ich bei diesem unfall und ich bin heute
morgen erst den 458 von the frames
gefahren und jetzt überspringen wir
quasi eine serie generation der
mittelmotorsportwagen die 488 haben sie
nicht und es geht direkt zum 18 man
merkt hier rein da ist das glasdach die
roten zylinderköpfen megageil das happy
end hat diese rückleuchten
dahingehend zu wieder der 80 superstars
ist einfach ist einfach sexy
ich finde auspuffanlage sieht brave
außer ich bin 54 mit dem 2 3 in damit
auf jeden fall ja klar sagen ja 720 ps
3,9 liter v8 biturbo wie hier 880 auch
schon und ja das war einfach für die
touristen auf der ganz ganz gesang
funktion vor spielende mega
sexy eine ist echt sexy die möglichkeit
hat man muss das sein ist aber einfach
nicht ganz so die füße nachziehen ich
hab ich so ein ding das ich mal ist
vorwärts reinfall deiner größe ist halt
auch nicht ob sich über also ja nochmal
visier eine geil geil drehzahlmesser ist
noch analog das ist sehr sehr nice leute
wenn ihr mich immer warum guckt quasi in
den tunnel hier reinkommt mal
drehzahlmesser der irgendwie links die
displays wie beim 458 drehzahlmesser ist
aber noch analog des nice der roma die
wir fahren nach wie vor am kanal
komplett genau der roma war quasi dann
sehr vorgestellt wurde somit das oder
war das erste modell wo wirklich
komplett alles dann digital war das
heißt er wirklich den komplett großen
bildschirm in der mitte das fahrer
display und hat sogar weil es ja mehr
oder weniger dann der alltags ferrari
ist sogar auch noch in der mitte einen
großen bildschirm oder an das navi läuft
wo multimedia handy und so weiter also
der roma den wir später noch sehen der
hat auf jeden fall dass das komplette
digitale pakete und da bin ich auch sehr
gespannt drauf aber wir haben hier keine
daumen hupen wenn ich hier reinschauen
leute der 458 hat die hier so daumen
hoch
damit man wenn man da durch die
düsseldorfer innenstadt für die leute
weg vorfeld der ohne die hand vom
lenkrad zu nehmen ja also man sieht auch
leute also ich war ja die watt
beziehungsweise im alltag eine e-klasse
kranker kontrast sowieso ganz anderes
auto aber auch die ganze
konzeptionierung vom innenraum zwei
kleine displays hier vorne und hier ist
er gar nichts bei der e klasse gefühl
die kinoleinwände in mehrfacher
ausführung kannst die avatar anschauen
in 3d
und hier ist halt alles simpel
sportwagen und dem mittelmotor hinter
dir ja ich würde sagen und damit sind
wir drin leute ja ok ja digital ist
alles nur du hast den schlüssel
das ist für diese extra eine halterung
für
man trägt sieht was man erfährt er erst
mal nur mit drehzahlen zeigt im lenkrad
geil wenn der drehzahlbegrenzer
begrenzer mit den leds oberen carbon
lenkrad
das ist ja so riesig alter genau damit
noch mal einen richtigen fan auch weiß
was man haben wollte ist es wirklich
krank müssen so real also sehr so real
dass jetzt hier wirklich drinsitzen
machen das fenster runter würde ich
sagen dass man jetzt ein anderer macht
uns gegenüber wir machen wir mit jetzt
hat uns die wanderer zurück
cinemaxx dieses lenkrad haben
es grüßt schon heute gefahren von daher
bräuchte nicht viel erklären dass auch
[Musik]
ein linker am lenkrad
so nah ist also das fühlt sich gar nicht
an als wirklich ihren gatten sportwagen
mit 27 ps fahren
das ist unfassbar stabil und ruhig und
ja also mittlerweile das muss man
wirklich sagen die verlage jetzt echt
geschafft gerade auch bei diesen
eigentlich punkten sportwagen dass das
so hinzukriegen dass man die mehr oder
weniger auch relativ entspannt im alltag
fahren kann
guckt euch das mal an leute das ist
sogar für den beifahrer einfach den mann
eine anzeige hat dann wird das ganze
aussehen
ich stelle mir gerade am band sind und
welcher geschwindigkeit sie können die
aussteller waren sind das finde ich
sogar um 8 12 es erst mal gesehen kann
es sein das ist dann kann der form kommt
dass beifahrer display an sich schon
lange dass ihr habt ja auch um 480 schon
ja aber jetzt indem ich sage mal in der
qualität der sozusagen
bis jetzt
aachen 12
da kann man schon relativ bald der
fahrer kann hier immer noch ein bisschen
rum spielen sich das anzeigen lassen was
er gerne hätte also von radio übernahm
über die performance ist natürlich mit
einem spannendsten ist kann er sich da
alles anzeigen das geil digger mega
krass die bremse mega massig fühlte sich
irgendwie an als so als wisse so die
masse so bewegen oder so cultra weil es
nicht auch gigantische bremsscheiben ein
bürger sagen also die bremsscheiben und
auch die bremssättel das ist natürlich
schon gebucht und 720 ps müssen
natürlich auch irgendwie zum stehen
kommt
aber trotz alledem also ich finde das
fühlt sich trotzdem nicht zu schwer an
die bremse ist immer noch sehr schön
also klar sehr sportlich das gehört hat
sie bei den herren natürlich dazu aber
ein bisschen gefühl hatte ich das gefühl
dass man da irgendwie zu krass
und ich finde es echt krass wie sehr man
den motor und alles rausnehmen kann so
aus dem fahren wenn man möchte
das hat ja fast schon sowas gt artiges
ja als man ist ein reiner sport waren
klaren ja aber der hat die so langsam
auch die qualitäten findet ja also das
ist das ist beim roman natürlich ein
anderes wenn man da im komfort modus
fährt dann hört man sage ich mal nahezu
nichts wenn man das denn möchte aber
auch wo auch bei der fracht wenn
weil das unter 2 3000 umdrehungen ja man
weiß hier nochmal hat da was im nacken
aber es
war noch alles relativ entspannten
flüstert ein so nur so
gute nachrichten von der flüsse aber ich
bin da wenn du möchtest genau kann ich
auch noch mehr wenn man zu lange sagt
dass es mich genau das ist jetzt also
martino hier unten ist jetzt auf sport
genau wenn wir dann auf race gehen dann
macht er alles klappen auch und was
heißt also dass hier keine klappen okay
das ist nicht mehr so erlaubten genau
das ist ja nicht mehr so gehalten
aber wenn die katzen bisschen wärmer
werden dann auch höhere drehzahlen wir
gleich mal vielleicht fahren hört man
schon diesen touristischen und auch den
hat den klassischen ferrari sohn 3 also
im ersten moment denkt man sich
vielleicht gehen jetzt endlich ein
bisschen leise für eine für sony aber
spätestens werde mit dem gleich mal ein
bisschen sportlicher bewegen und
ein bisschen temperatur hat
erkennt man schon nicht dass das wieder
der fall den wir vom ferrari liga ja ich
hab's ja auch gerade als wir den von
außen mal gehört haben um gefahren wurde
auf dem parkplatz
das ist nicht so dass man das ich denke
mein gott da kann ich morgens nicht
losfahren zuhause geben tatsächlich
relativ ruhig noch in der garage staaten
ja wenn man dann irgendwann auf der
autobahn angekommen ist dann
kann man richtig schön fliegen lassen
lenkungs auch aktiv also die verteilt
sind genau die leben noch ein bisschen
knackiger ja gerade für die kurven dann
auf der rennstrecke
ob also dass man eben sport ohne es auch
[Musik]
dass wir auch gerade jetzt so auf einen
spannenden einstellungen von spann
handschellen ans lenkrad ja wirklich
viel bewegen und der
schießt sich durch die gegend ja also
gewarnt im alltag natürlich waren möchte
wir haben jetzt wasser wein und 80 grad
modell auf 76 motor ist schon betriebs
am wasser braucht 90
für uns gleich mal
in richtung landstraße das auch ein
bisschen
das ist wie leute wenn ihr die jungs
verstehen wenn ihr so lange kennen
gelernt hat was so richtig gut gefällt
dass es so kurz vom ersten date so
dass das gefühl wenn ihr auf jungs steht
natürlich auch ein junge
aber
bei mega den kurven da rutschte hier das
carbon lenkrad durch die hände
man hört man hat die turbos auf
ja ich halte meine der 49
[Musik]
gail zappa
der wahrscheinlich ein
kleiner und kleiner funken oder einem
großen für diesen beiden gleichauf
die sitzung beide auf dem baum
sünder
[Musik]
liga
alter feiern
niklas heftig es sich empfiehlt mega
geil geil geil
das kind lag
krank heute ein kran kern und der ist
immer noch mit leicht 143 tonnen
das ist auch wirklich so ein gefühl fürs
bis an die bienen
[Musik]
das ist eine erfahrung
porsche werde
ja
wir sind jetzt schon langsam wieder an
zurück
am standort aber wir sind schon dadurch
auf jeden fall bevor wir zur battle
kommen bleibt bis zum ende dran und
checkt in der endart das video aus dem
kanal von ferrari düsseldorf
ja damit jetzt an mich selbst zu
bekämpfen sebastian wir kommen wir damit
die bewertungen leute die natürlich wie
immer mit dem aus den anfängen der
ferrari f 8 tributo ist eine absolute
wucht von außen ein wunderschönes auto
und holt ganz locker 9 von 10 punkten
die beschleunigung ist einfach brutal
null auf hundert in 2,9 sekunden das
sind easy 10 von 10 und man muss auch
sagen der schiebt einfach immer weiter
wie eine woche bei 240 km/h drückt er
ein noch in den sitz das ist einfach
unglaublich und ganz ehrlich genauso
sieht es bei der grünen das außen
nagelneuer ferrari zehn von zehn gar
keine frage
spaß wert und insgesamt damit 29 von 30
punkten und platz eins in der spaß
wertung urteilen mit der praktikabilität
ist hat natürlich wieder nicht so gut
aus drei vor zehn jahren auch gibt
natürlich nicht mehr als bei germanys
458 italia die dinger sind einfach nicht
praktisch müssen ja auch gar nicht preis
leistungsmäßig jetzt auch ähnlich aus
wie beim 458 italia allerdings war der
italia gebraucht dadurch ein bisschen
günstiger und es gibt entsprechend sechs
von zehn hier sondern 15
in der letzten kategorie dem komfort war
ich sehr beeindruckt von diesem auto man
denkt wirklich nicht dass der so ruhig
und entspannt zu fahren ist im unteren
drehzahlbereich und wenn man eben nicht
bald bin ich wirklich wirklich sehr
überrascht gewesen allerdings sehe ich
ihn vom komfort her nicht auf einem
level mit zum beispiel im z 44 oder den
beiden 911 an und es gibt hier vier von
zehn punkten alltags wert und damit 12
und 30 und insgesamt 41 von 60 für einen
ganz klar fokussierten sportwagen einen
bomben wert in der gesamtwertung und wie
gesagt platz eins in der spaß wertung h
auto ein bisschen mehr sound und das
wäre perfekt
damit bis nächste woche leute vielen
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und macht's
gut